foreign
about this daily cancellation I finally
get a chance to cancel Ann Hathaway I've
held a grudge against this woman ever
since my wife early in our marriage
forced me to go to the theater with her
and uh and with her mom and her sister
to watch Les Miserables it was the worst
experience of my life every actor in the
film was deeply and painfully annoying
none of them would stop singing at all
they sang the entire time from start to
finish yet even amidstall of that Anne
Hathaway managed to be irritating and
insufferable on a level that even
Russell Crowe's blubbering off-key
performance couldn't reach a couple of
years later I went with much higher
hopes to go see Interstellar and there
was Anne Hathaway again helping to ruin
the film with her cringy saccharin
speeches about the Transcendent Power of
Love
I wanted to see a movie about deep space
exploration I was hoping there'd be
aliens instead I got no aliens only a
little bit of space exploration in
exchange for a lot of scenes of Anne
Hathaway and Jessica Chastain sulking
and whining and giving corny sermons so
the only thing that would made it worse
is if they started singing which
thankfully they didn't all that to say
this cancellation is a long time coming
Hathaway's appearance this week on The
View has uh I think finally provided me
the opportunity that I've been waiting
for
let's watch
you know the devilish product didn't
turn 16 this summer yes the time flies
boy so you wrote this on Instagram quote
I am struck by the fact that the young
female characters in this movie built
their lives and careers in a country
then honored their right to have Choice
over their own reproductive Health see
you in the fight so why did you write
that why was it important to you to you
to write something like that because
we're in the fight yeah we're in the
fight every day we're in the fight every
minute and you mentioned the devil's
product turning sweet 16 yeah some 16
year old's life has been irrevocably
changed yeah because of the current
overturning of Roe v Wade and in this
character I played a young woman who was
starting out her career and when you are
a young woman starting out your career
your reproductive Destiny matters a
great deal of course and I just
it had just happened and I just
I think about it all the time I think we
all think about it all the time and um
and what's implications are and what it
means to live in a country that
puts us in this position again again
yeah yeah again and so if I were to play
that role nowadays I couldn't take that
for granted I couldn't take that freedom
for granted the freedom of choice and by
the way I'm not this is not a moral
conversation about abortion right this
is a practical conversation about
women's rights and by the way human
rights because women's rights are human
rights and the freedom that we all need
to be able to to choose and build our
lives and have access to excellent
Health Care see this is exactly what you
did in in interstellar just babbling and
coherently of course if you listen to
any leftists when they talk about
abortion or really any other subject at
all all that any of them do is Babble
incoherently so let's try to sift
through this she says that uh it Grieves
her to consider that the young female
characters in Devil Wears Prada would
not be able to have abortions if the
film was set in the current day it is to
begin with extremely strange to worry
about the availability of abortion for
fictional characters
um now I I've never seen The Devil Wears
Prada but I'm pretty sure that the film
is largely set in New York
women in New York can still get
abortions unless they don't exist
because they're fictional which is a
logistical problem that will prevent
them from doing a lot of things
including getting abortions also again
not having seen it my impression is that
the movie has a rather dim view of
selfish career-obsessed people
um that's like the Devil Wears Prada
that's so part of the moral of the story
from what I understand is that there's
more to life than professional ambition
yet Hathaway's takeaway is that women
need to be able to kill their children
so they can focus more on career
advancement
there seems to be a little bit of a
disconnect here she also speaks about
reproductive Destiny which of course is
exactly the sort of asinine hackneyed
phrase you would expect Anne Hathaway to
use when discussing abortion
um it's it's it's not the sort of
wording that I would ever choose
but since she brought it up
let us ask this question
reproductive Destiny Okay well once a
woman has conceived a child
what is her reproductive Destiny the
word destiny implies a force outside of
the individual a message a mission from
Beyond ourselves so what is this Force
call it nature call it the universe call
it as I do God what is this Force trying
to say to the woman what is her Destiny
now that she has conceived the child in
her womb is it her Destiny to partake in
the joy and beauty and fulfillment of
motherhood
or is it her Destiny to Peg some
abortionist to kill her baby and throw
his body into a medical waste dumpster
I would say the former
indeed how could it be anyone's
reproductive Destiny to reject their
reproductive capacity and violently
destroy the human life that they have
reproduced
to call such a choice reproductive
Destiny seems uh bizarre to say the
least
Hathaway also claims that she's not
interested in having a moral
conversation about abortion but rather a
practical conversation about women's
rights
well except that a conversation about
rights is automatically a conversation
about morality you cannot extract the
concept of morality from the concept of
Human Rights
a practical conversation a real
practical conversation is one that is
not concerned with theories or ideas at
all
but but human rights are a theory they
are an idea
they're a moral idea that isn't to say
they don't exist
rather that they exist in the moral
realm they don't exist physically
practically like a chair or a rock or
the ocean exists so to say that you
don't want to talk about morality you
just want to talk about human rights
that is to speak gibberish human rights
are a moral concept the minute you bring
them up you have entered into the moral
Realm
but that's not where Anne Hathaway wants
to be because she knows that she can't
actually defend abortion on moral
grounds none of these people can
and that's the issue
but she had more to say and it only gets
dumber from here so let's continue
another thing and just without going
into too many details my own personal
experience with abortion and I don't
think we talk about this enough abortion
can be another word for Mercy we don't
know we don't know it's not a world in
which we know that no two pregnancies
are alike and it follows that no two
lives are like that follows that no two
conceptions are alike so how can we have
a law how can we have a point of view on
this that says we must treat everything
the same and where I come at it from is
when you allow for choice you allow for
flexibility which is what we need in
order to be human so that anyway I just
wanted to include that
especially for that it's not it's not
set in stone just because you get
pregnant doesn't mean you get to keep
that baby yeah it's a health decision
and it can be it really can be yeah
abortion is another word for Mercy she
says but Mercy for whom
Mercy for the child who's being killed
that's not Mercy the child has an entire
life ahead of him or he should
you're taking that away You're deciding
for him that his life is not worth
living you're erasing all of his
potential all that could have been
and you're not giving him a choice in
the matter
there's no mercy in that it's the
opposite of Mercy because it's the
opposite of empathy and you can't have
mercy without empathy
or do you mean that it's merciful to the
woman are you saying that killing a
child is an act of Mercy to the child's
mother
well no mercy to the mother is to help
her to give her the resources she needs
Mercy is what pregnancy centers provide
Mercy is their Ministry it's what they
do
abortion clinics on the other hand are
vultures
they prey on fear and misery they cash
in on it they feed off of it they profit
off of it
they sell guilt they sell regret they
sell loneliness
while taking away the love and joy of
motherhood that's not Mercy it's
mercenary
so whichever way Hathaway meant it she's
wrong
though I'm not sure she knows how she
meant it because she's just babbling
which is what most defenses of abortion
boil down to incoherent Babel
and that is why Ann Hathaway is today
finally after all these years canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]